ukraine's top prosecutor is due to meet
her counterpart from the international
criminal court in the hague later today
they'll be looking at how best to
coordinate investigations into alleged
war crimes by russian soldiers in
ukraine some trials have already begun
thanks to meticulous documentation on
the ground but investigating potential
war crimes could be more of a challenge
in regions where russia has taken
control
a warning our next report contains some
disturbing images from the start
images that no one should have to see
civilians strewn across a street in
butcher
the immediate aftermath of a strike on a
maternity hospital in mariupol
a mass grave holding the unidentified
bodies of fathers mothers brothers
sisters grandparents and children
after ukrainian fighters pushed russian
forces back from towns and villages
they'd occupied
evidence of atrocities began to pile up
all being documented by human rights
groups ukrainian officials and
journalists on the ground
now almost two months later ukraine's
prosecutor general says investigations
are underway into well over 10 000
suspected war crimes
ranging from pillaging and looting rape
and summary execution to indiscriminate
bombing of civilian infrastructure
the first war crimes trial concluded
last week resulting in a guilty verdict
for a 21 year old russian soldier
charged with shooting an unarmed
ukrainian man
but in the eastern donbass region where
the war is still being fought tracking
down evidence and prosecuting potential
war crimes could prove a lot more
difficult
in the southern city of mariupol aerial
pictures showed the word children dogged
outside the theater building that was
hit by russian airstrikes in march
an associated press investigation
suggests as many as 600 people may have
been killed there as they sought shelter
ukraine says russia knew it was a
civilian target
now mariupol is in russian hands
and an independent investigation at the
site has been impossible
exactly who and how many people died
there may never be known
in april satellite images showed
apparent mass graves near the city
local officials say up to 9 000 bodies
could be buried there victims of russian
aggression they say
now russia is focusing its assault on
the luhansk region
the fear is if more towns and cities
fall under russian control the harder it
will become to investigate potential war
crimes and hold anyone there to account
earlier i spoke to hugh williamson from
human rights watch in berlin and i asked
him how long it could actually take to
investigate the thousands of suspected
war crimes in ukraine
good morning and thanks for having me um
i certainly hope so
obviously it's difficult to estimate how
long it's going to take it's important
that
investigations teams have already
started as you heard in your report the
ukrainian prosecutor's office is busy
with this issue
international criminal court has sent
experts to ukraine as well it's
important that these teams are well
coordinated
sharing resources supporting the
prosecutor's office in the work they're
doing
um and on that basis
um
the work needs to be thorough and
independent but obviously needs to move
forward as fast as possible
so what are the the problems that
investigators are confronting right now
while they're collecting evidence of
potential war crimes
i mean evidently where this is happening
in the midst of a war and that poses
huge problems security problems for
those investigating
problems of
securing the evidence
allowing access for forensic experts
and so on
ukrainian authorities are obviously
extremely stretched and therefore they
do need
support from other prosecution uh teams
and so on other other european countries
have also sent teams to to ukraine so
resources are an important point but
also independence is a vital point as
well um
you know
ukraine is in the middle of a war and
therefore
sense a sense of sort of
national pride and anti-russian
sentiment is obviously strong
nevertheless the prosecutor's office
needs to assess things through the
judicial lens and make sure that trials
are free and fair which is a challenging
task for them in a war situation but
it's absolutely vital for that to happen
if the the results and the verdicts are
to be seen as credible in the longer
term
now we see more and more evidence of uh
alleged war crimes in regions that
russian troops have left should we
expect any investigations to take place
in the area still held by the russians
um i mean it is obviously difficult for
difficult if not impossible for
investigators to go there regarding
russian war crimes nevertheless
um it's possible to gather evidence
human rights watch for instance in
mariopol one of the main cities now
seemingly under russian control has been
gathering evidence for weeks and weeks
there
both
remotely through
assessing videos photos that have been
placed online and so on looking at
patterns of bombing by russia
for instance but also by interviewing
people who have left maori or poll we've
done a whole range of interviews with
people in towns relatively nearby so
it's certainly possible to gather
evidence
in real time as it were and to make that
available to prosecutors so they can
start building cases even for
in areas which are still under russian
control
hugh williamson there from human rights
watch thank you very much
thanks for your time